oh
[Musique]
magie quand tu nous tiens salut c'est
monsieur bret aujourd'hui on est à
madrid partie avec schumi pour aller
découvrir le mit 2 à le nouveau
smartphone qui va être présenté dès
demain matin mais on va pas attendre une
concentration de produits pour parler de
schumi aujourd'hui vous présenter un
produit qui est plutôt cool c'est le
réduit 6 à un produit qui nous vient
tout droit de chine qu'il faut encore
sorti en france
je sais pas sortir un jour donc ce que
je propose c'est de découvrir youri va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui je vous emmène avec moi à
madrid on va aller au lancement de firmi
du mit à 2 et du miel de light vous
allez voir des trucs super cool alors
c'est pas aujourd'hui grosse pensée les
smartphones ce sera demain
par contre aujourd'hui en faire un petit
tour de madrid j'ai aussi un smartphone
de chez un ami à vous montrer donc en
profiter est pour l'instant en train de
l'avion
[Musique]
d
oh
ouais
bien arriver là je vais récupérer ma
piaule théâtre sont deux or que c'est à
dire y va mal tout ça pas mal du tout
dire elle a quand même
regardez-moi ça grand lit si bonne
petite entrée sympathique petit meuble
télé ici petit coin lecture bosser
surtout bossé très important mon balcon
mais c'est strictement impossible d'y
accéder
c'est bloqué c'est malgré tout très
jolie la vue d'en face petite salle de
bains cosy là je crois qu'on est quand
même plutôt pas mal
petite salle de bains est derrière nous
avons petit wc petite douche à jets
plaira bon ben je pense caprica bon la
douche ça sera pour plus tard n'est
plutôt pas mal de coins là franchement
on est bien reçu du côté de chez oh oui
merci beaucoup je crois qu'elle sut la
chaume estime qu'elles ont envie de
pâques et là franchement ça c'est bien
regardez moi ces petites mourir sur le
côté comme c'est pas mignon
des jolis petits colvert magnifique pour
demain ses lancements de millas de sio
me je propose de parler d'un autre
produit choï aujourd'hui on va donc
faire deux jours spécial c'est au mit
donc rester connecté parce que vous
allez voir demain et la présentation il
ya ensuite une prise en main pendant
leur garde et on va le tester puis on
testera pour détails plus tard dont vous
avez tout de suite à vous connecter à
vous abonner
vous allez tout plutôt cool et donc tout
de suite on va parler d'un autre
smartphone 2 xiaomi qui est sorti a pas
très longtemps qui pour l'instant n'est
pas dispo en france mais qui pourrait
arriver très prochainement je vous
présente leurs ennemis 6 à tous toute
toute petite boîte alors on est dans un
smartphone d'entrée de gamme qui est
pour l'instant dispo à moins de 100
euros s'est guère best si vous intéresse
connaissais je vous ai mis un lien en
bas d'un description pouvait les voir
c'est vrai que la boîte est tout
particulièrement minuscule faut pas
regarder ce qui est à l'intérieur
ouverture
leicester alors c'est vraiment mini mini
modèles raid mi6
ah voilà vous l'avez là où petit
smartphone qui fait son poids c'est une
version globale rien est écrit en
français dans d'ailleurs c'est un modèle
qui est disponible uniquement en anglais
donc si vous craignez pas l'anglais et
que vous devrez smartphone pas trop cher
pour retrouver celui là alors qu'avant
nous dans la boîte
nous avons ici petite notice
d'information écrites exclusivement
chinois donc si vous parlez chinois vous
verrez c'est super on a ensuite de quoi
le branché mais pour saga sûr il vous
faudra un theater secteur un port micro
usb vers usb donc peut très facilement
le chargé avec un chargeur un peu
classique celui là par contre il vous
servira uniquement pour les voyages vous
avez au fond de petites piques
on y trouve votre tiroir de cartes sim
hop voilà le smartphone comme ça à l'air
d'être plutôt cool alors effectivement
c'est un prix d'entrée de gamme donc on
va pas attendre de lui des miracles il
va pas être complètement révolutionnaire
vous avez ici une caméra de 13
mégapixels avec ici un petit flash à
l'avant une caméra de 5 mégapixels pas
d'info sur l'ouverture seul point
négatif de ce modèle il est disponible
uniquement en anglais
bon après on chinois et plein d'autres
langues mais normalement ça c'est plutôt
l'anglais pour vous donc si vous ne
parlez pas anglais va falloir passer
votre tour sur ce modèle là dessus vous
avez un écran de 5 45 pouces et une dali
ps cdu a cédé avec une résolution de
1440 par 720 pixels et un ratio 18/9 à
l'intérieur c'est un processeur st
médiathèque ainsi 1762 cadencé jusqu'à 2
giga hertz de giga de ram 64 giga de
stockage extensible
vous avez une batterie de 3000 millions
terreur à l'intérieur du bluetooth 4
points de la possibilité de mettre une
double carte sim
elle tourne sur un android 8 points avec
une surcouche me lui n'est point zéro
bon alors à qui s'adresse ce smartphone
parce que très clairement c'est un
smartphone qui est pas cher c'est un
smartphone d'entrée de gamme à moins de
100 euros forcément moins de 100 euros
doit pas s'adresser à tout le monde et
surtout si vous ne parlez pas anglais ce
modèle là n'est pas du tout fait pour
vous s'il fait qu'ils sont en anglais
c'est pas rédhibitoire vous pouvez y
aller derrière vous avez un dock
plastique un de plastique avec un faux
effet métal sait pas forcément ce qu
oracle coûte un peu plus premium mais
bon fondamentalement ça fait la faire en
bas vous avez des petits trous sur le
haut une prise directe ça c'est plutôt
cool sur le côté bon des boutons
classiques ont-elles de sept volumes
allumé
éteindre votre tiroir carte s'initie il
se recharge en micro usb bien évidemment
pas 10 des tips et sur un modèle de ce
prix là mais bon comme ça il est plutôt
cool pas très cher il n'ya pas non plus
de 14 en train digital pour le
déverrouiller il va falloir faire votre
petit schéma ou alors taper un code à
quatre chiffres pas de reconnaissance
faciale
mais une fois de plus c'est un
smartphone à moins de 100 euros
on va pas lui demander la lune au niveau
des photos et des vidéos vous pouvez
filmer en 1080p aux films en 720p si
vous voulez il faut pas trop l'intérêt
vous avez une même photo vidéo notre
portrait panorama taille l'attend à tous
les grands classiques qu'on peut
retrouver sur les modèles du chien au
oui avec le 1008 9.0 ya du hdr il ya des
filtres pour ajouter sur vos images
il ya le mode beauty faille la détection
automatique de scène avec l'intelligence
artificielle ce que vous propose d'aller
faire un tour à l'extérieur pour
attester les caméras avant arrière filmé
deux trois trucs et puis on va les voir
en finale ce que ça dit c'est parti pour
un tour à l'extérieur
chafic est
une chaleur à madrid on crève pour ça
pour l'instant ça a l'air d'être plutôt
pas mal en termes de photos vidéos et
attention pas de stabilisation
vous le prenez si vous bougez un peu sa
trempe ça pardonne absolument rien
musée du prado est lâchée sur les
canadiens de cette ville comme ça on
teste et on se balade on découvre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur les caméras de ces le fil la qualité
vidéo et pas trop ordinaire c'est un
petit peu un peu criard mais bon ça fait
la faire avec fois de plus caméra de 5
mégapixels smartphone à moins de 100
euros
ça me semble me répéter mais au final ça
va pas david mendel elle une bon et là
sans la caméra principale c'est pas mal
le rendu global mans est assez correcte
qui cassent pas quatre pattes à un
canard on va pas avoir un vrai effet
bloqué parce qu'on n'a pas de double
objectif à l'arrière c'est pas un
smartphone révolutionnaire c'est du déjà
vu et du revu du rheu corriger mais pour
tous ceux qui veulent du xiaomi pas cher
à moins de 100 euros peuvent se faire
plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors verdict deux soeurs ennemies 6
alors déjà un point négatif et pas des
moindres ça forcément il faut tenir
compte si ce produit vous intéresse
c'est très clairement un produit qui
n'est pas du tout traduit en français je
dis je le redis je le redis peut-être
que laisser quelques toiles sortir en
france c'est pas impossible pour
l'instant ce produit il faut l'importer
si vous intéresse il faut le faire venir
donc pas de version française si ça
c'est pas rédhibitoire on peut continuer
à avancer
le smartphone est globalement pas trop
mal qu'à spa quatre pattes à un canard à
ce quelque chose qu'on a déjà vu revu
revue revu sa smartphone entrée de gamme
et il a rien à voir avec les smartphones
haut de gamme le 1008 et compagnie elle
qu'on peut trouver chez omis celui-là il
assez classique assez standard pour ceux
qui veulent un smartphone shiomi pas
cher pourront aussi retrouver bat donc
pour street view dur nbc s'appela on va
profiter des trains à madrid pour le
faire un petit tour je vous montre et
surtout mon hôtel vous allez voir c'est
un truc complètement dingos que nous a
dégoté chez omis dans un quartier hyper
classe à côté du prado super beau super
mignon et puis ce soir à une soirée
tapas sangria mon avis ça va déchirer le
très juste immense mais perd 1,2 au
sixième étage salle de fitness très bien
moi j'ai juste hâte et voir l'agent
redescend au quatrième étage à ma piaule
super gars des attaques des couloirs
si vous vous y retrouvez
bravo c'est très très grand c'est de
trouver ta chambre
c'est les six mois 402 c'est trop long
bon alors bilan de la soirée a eu
quelque chose comme 89 qu'il soirée
tapas petite soirée tapas pas mal
sangria bien van rouge espagnole de
madrid
très bon est ce que vous saviez cas
maryse avait un petit vin rouge
sympathie incroyable donc là je suis
quasiment à la fin de la vidéo
c'est quasiment fini le montage est bien
claire d'aller se coucher parce que si
quelques heures on va se lever puis vous
emmener avec moi donc rester connecté
abonnez-vous parce que pour vous c'est
demain pour moi c'est dans quelque chose
comme cette heure on va aller faire un
tour du côté de la conf de presse de
chimie pourra découvrir leur tout
nouveau smartphone bien une interview la
clé pas mal de choses là le montage se
termine tout doucement
quelques heures de sommeil ça va être
dur en tout cas merci à vous d'apprendre
et cette vidéo je vous ai dit une fois
de plus si ce smartphone nous intéresse
vous ai mis tous les liens dans la
description et puis d'ici là soyez vous
embrasse plein dentifrice bécaud bécaud
et à demain